tell me a little bit about George  Berkeley did he not come up with these  ideas that the moon does not exist  except when you're looking at it except  if you have sort of this God's eye  perspective talk about Berkeley  irrelevant or is he more relevant than  ever he has this view that even if I'm  not looking at a tree the tree exists  only because it's in God's view so God  keeps things existing by perceiving them  but he said to be is to be perceived or  to be a perceiver so that's a very very  different point of view than a  physicalist view that says you know  space time energy and matter are the  fundamental Natures of objective reality  and Barkley was saying no the  fundamental nature of existence is being  perceived or being a perceiver